recently cryptocurrencies haven't had
the best of times bitcoin and ethereum
are down nearly 50
while many altcoins are down 70 to 80
and this makes sense given that interest
in bitcoin nfts and crypto in general
have fallen off substantially during
such downturns one of the most desirable
positions within the market is being the
person who's selling the shovels of
course crypto brokerages aren't making
nearly as much money as they used to
given lower trading volume and their own
stocks have been hammered by the market
coinbase for example is down nearly 70
percent from their all-time high
but despite this coinbase should still
be profitable meaning that they're able
to turn a profit in any sort of market
conditions
and as you would guess the guy behind
coinbase and brian armstrong is still
doing quite well with the net worth of
just over 5 billion dollars ironically
brian's net worth stood at 16 billion
just 12 months ago this means that his
average net worth over the past year is
about 10 billion dollars depending on
how the crypto markets are performing
coinbase however hasn't even been a
thing for 10 years at this point so
here's how brian armstrong made 10
billion dollars in 10 years
taking a look back brian's story dates
back to january 25th 1983 to san jose
california brian was born to a pretty
well-off family of engineers and from a
very young age he had a pretty strong
inclination towards technology nowadays
this is nothing special given that this
basically applies to all of us but back
in the 1980s and 90s average people were
just starting to buy their first
computers during high school it looks
like brian was the classic computer geek
who chose to learn java and css during
his free time brian recalls that getting
strange looks from his peers due to his
quote nerdiness was extremely common
weird looks weren't the only thing that
is coding skills got him though brian
was able to leverage his skills to
design websites and programs for local
businesses and earn some money on the
side soon enough ryan would graduate
from high school in 2001 and he would
attend rice university where he double
majored in computer science and
economics while he likely performed
great in school he never put all of his
eggs in one basket during college he
opened up a website that could match
tutors with students called
universitytutor.com the service wasn't
anything particularly special but brian
was rather early to the game having
launched to serve this in june of 2003
so he was able to capture quite a bit of
market share and this would turn into a
full-time job over the next several
years brian didn't drop out of college
either though
instead he would actually go on to
complete a master's in computer science
at rice university right after he
finishes bachelor's brian also got an
internship at ibm where he helped them
create some java based tools that could
be used in conjunction with the network
attached storage devices
anyway shortly after finishing college
bryan would decide to take a one-year
trip to buenos aires argentina and this
trip would turn out to be extremely
influential you see argentina has been
struggling with a chronic inflation
problem for decades in 2004 you could
only get 2.81 argentine pesos with one
dollar
today however you can get
114.39 argentine pesos meaning that the
currency is worth 40 times less relative
to the dollar
living in buenos aires brian was
witnessing this crisis firsthand and
this didn't give him a particularly
positive view towards fiat currency
after brian returned to the us he
continued serving as the ceo of
universitytutor.com
but i don't think you'd be surprised to
hear that brian was also constantly on
the lookout for new opportunities one of
these opportunities was working at
airbnb as a software engineer
at the time airbnb was operating in 190
countries and brian had a chance to work
on their international payment systems
this experience made him realize just
how difficult it was to send and receive
money in certain developing countries
and this would give him the final push
he needed to go all in on coinbase
while it wasn't till mid 2012 that brian
left university tutor and went all in on
coinbase by this point he had already
been working on the idea for a few years
in the background brian first heard
about bitcoin in december of 2010 when
he came across bitcoin's white paper
being a serial entrepreneur since high
school brian instantly knew that he had
to try something in this space but he
wasn't sure what exactly to do initially
it seems like brian was interested in
creating something like venmo or square
but for bitcoin however he quickly
realized that bitcoin wasn't that great
when it came to transactions due to its
high fees so instead he decided to just
focus on helping people buy and hold
crypto and this of course led him down
the path of starting a crypto brokerage
over the next two years brian would
spend all of his free time writing code
that would allow users to buy and store
various cryptocurrencies brian also
spent a lot of his time on the bitcoin
subreddit to better understand what
crypto enthusiasts were looking for and
this is when brian would run into a man
named fred ursum fred had a classic wall
street job as a foreign exchange trader
at goldman sachs in his free time he
liked to trade bitcoin and this is what
led him to the bitcoin subreddit as you
might have guessed brian and fred would
quickly become friends and fred would
join coinbase as a co-founder the duo
was also able to secure 150 000 worth of
startup capital from y combinator which
helped tremendously with initial startup
expenses and with that the duo launched
coinbase on june 20th 2012. at the time
coinbase was one of the only choices you
had if you wanted to conveniently buy
bitcoin within the us so naturally all
of the original crypto enthusiasts
flocked over to coinbase kraken and
bitstamp for many of these guys the
brokerage didn't matter all that much
given that they had no plans of keeping
their coins on the brokerage most of
these guys instantly transfer their
coins into their bitcoin wallets and
eventually into cold storage options
nonetheless coinbase was able to make
quite a bit of money with each bitcoin
purchase or sale thanks to their hefty
commission fees
even today their fees are rather high
especially in comparison to the stock
market for example if you buy 10 000
worth of crypto you have to pay coinbase
between 40 and 60
despite these fees coinbase has never
really struggled with a lack of interest
given that crypto returns are so high
that these fees often seem insignificant
in comparison within just the first two
years of launching coinbase was able to
grow to 1 million users and this
exponential growth made it extremely
easy to raise money in may of 2013 union
square ventures invested 5 million
dollars into coinbase at the time this
seemed like an extremely risky move
given that this was the biggest funding
run in bitcoin startup history but
knowing that the stake would eventually
grow to 4.6 billion dollars i think it
worked out just fine
just a couple of months after this when
base would raise another 25 million
dollars and with that they were off to
the races
using all this newfound capital brian
would continue making coinbase more
secure for example in 2014 brian
purchased entrants for all of the
bitcoin stored on coinbase servers
similarly coinbase also launched their
vault system which is supposed to offer
extremely secure bitcoin storage such
initiatives made coinbase customers feel
a lot more comfortable and many of them
started to hold their crypto inside
coinbase itself
aside from upping the reliability of
coinbase brian also worked on expanding
their features one of their biggest
launches came in 2015 when the company
came out with coinbase exchange this
exchange was more geared towards crypto
traders and enthusiasts and boasted
significant lower fees and smaller bid
ask spreads it also came along with more
sophisticated charts indicators and
limit orders yet i don't think coinbase
exchange was ever able to reach its full
potential first of all they had a
branding crisis for a few years
initially they were renamed a global
digital asset exchange before they were
eventually renamed coinbase pro
aside from this branding issue i don't
think coinbase pro actually ever reached
its target market even though coinbase
pro is an exceptional service and quite
popular the vast majority of people who
use coinbase pro are simply crypto
hodlers who want lower fees
it seems like the high frequency traders
far prefer the offerings from binance
which is evident in their substantially
higher trading volume coinbase currently
averages about 1 billion dollars per day
in trading volume meanwhile finance
averages nearly 30 billion per day in
trading volume clearly while coinbase
did not quite win over the trading
market this experience allowed them to
better understand their average customer
and position in the market coinbase
isn't the platform for traders it's the
platform for everyday crypto holders and
this became extremely evident during the
2017 bull run in the last quarter of
2017 coinbase's user count nearly
doubled in a matter of months we saw a
similar growth multiple in the first
quarter of 2021 as well brian has since
chosen to lean into the casual
demographic and launch features that
appeal to them for example in october of
2020 coinbase worked with visa to launch
their own debit card which apparently
offers up to four percent back in
rewards and more recently coinbase ran
an extremely successful ad at the 2022
super bowl the ad wasn't anything super
flashy or anything it was literally just
a qr code that was bouncing off the
walls of the screen however given that
it garnered 20 million hits in one
minute crashed into our coinbase website
and it caused coinbase to jump from 186
in the app store to number two i think
it's safe to say that the ad was a
roaring success and that brings us to
where we are today
likely the biggest event for coinbase in
recent history aside from the super bowl
added is their ipo
unfortunately though unlike the super
bowl added their ipo was not a roaring
success the ipo was actually extremely
hyped and people bought in significantly
on the day of the ipo but coinbase has
sold off ever since
also something that we should note is
that the peak of bitcoin was literally
on the exact day that coinbase ipo'd
bitcoin did go on to make a new all-time
high last november but this new peak was
only marginally higher than the old peak
and i think the general consensus is
that the april peak was a much more
significant peak so coinbase's ipo was
literally the peak of the crypto market
this is quite ironic given that coinbase
usually has the opposite effect on
crypto whenever a crypto is listed on
coinbase it often sources given that a
lot more people are able to buy the
given crypto but i guess coinbase
themselves being listed was bad luck for
the crypto market at least in the short
term looking forward given that crypto
is still only in its infancy it's likely
that coinbase has significant growth
left both in terms of their total user
count and their average holdings per
user and at this rate i think that brian
is on track to hit the 100 billion mark
within the next 10 to 20 years if not
sooner and fortunately brian is trying
his best to put all this wealth to good
use a few years ago he founded
givecrypto.com which is a non-profit
that distributes cryptocurrency to
people living in poverty he has also
assigned the giving pledge which means
that he has pledged to give away the
vast majority of his wealth considering
these wholesome ambitions i believe he
deserves all the success he's achieved
so far but that's just what i think
who's your favorite crypto brokerage
comment that down below
also drop a like if you're a fan of
crypto and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
our videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm hari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you